comment expliquer aux français ou aux
étrangers en situation régulière qui
travaillent dans notre pays qu une
réduction tarifaire dans les transports
soit accordée aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière bénéficiant de l'aide
médicale d'état
comment expliquer que même en cas
d'illégalité votre majorité continuera à
leur accorder des privilèges votre
position idéologique n'est pas audible
le président de la république aurait
d'ailleurs lui même rappelé aux cadres
de votre majorité que ce refus n'était
je cite qu'une connerie un peu plus d'un
an après l'instauration de 80 km la
réalité a rattrapé un peu tous les
discours qu'ils étaient tenus et qui
nous disait qu effectivement 10 km heure
en moins sur les réseaux secondaires
résoudrait les problèmes de la mortalité
l'année dernière on a pu se féliciter
d'une baisse de la mortalité en fin
d'année mais elle était déjà enclenchée
dès le début d'année avant le passage à
80 kilomètres on se rend compte que ces
six clips on se rend compte qu'il ya
bien d'autres paramètres qui sont
beaucoup plus décisif est beaucoup plus
important que ces 10 km heure
c'est le téléphone c'est l'alcool au
volant c'est le comportement des
automobilistes et c'est là-dessus avant
tout qu'il faut travailler
madame la ministre vous affirmiez en
avril que la grève dans les urgences de
plusieurs hôpitaux n'étaient pas dues
aux conditions de travail
aujourd'hui c'est la moitié des services
d'urgence publique qui sont en grève
acculé par la colère des personnels
soignants qui s'accroît vous présenter
en catastrophe un plan en trompe l'oeil
qui n'est pas à la hauteur de la
situation extrêmement tendue de nos
hôpitaux
loin de débloquer de nouveaux moyens
vous financez 12 mesures bien floues
contenues dans votre plan de 754
millions d'euros sur trois ans en
redéployant des moyens budgétaires déjà
existants prélevés sur d'autres services
on va donc déshabiller pierre pour
habiller paul on est loin d'une
refondation d urgence comme vous
l'annoncez la situation intenable que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui appel de
repenser l'hôpital dans sa globalité
vous ne répondez pas madame la ministre
aux demandes des personnels qui depuis
six mois
appelle à un moratoire sur la fermeture
des lits la revalorisation de leurs
salaires et surtout l'augmentation des
effectifs qui conditionne une prise en
charge satisfaisante n'est pas si rose
et madame la ministre quand allez vous
enfin entendre les appels de ces
milliers de professionnels qui ne désire
qu'une chose sauver l'hôpital et notre
système de santé
quand allez vous enfin prendre les
mesures indispensables à une réelle
réforme structurelle de nos hôpitaux
auquel tous les français c'est le 11
juin dernier monsieur le ministre vous
annonciez une série de mesures destinées
à rendre l'école pleinement inclusive
vous ajoutiez que les familles d'élèves
seraient mieux accompagner à la rentrée
2010 9
or sur le terrain force est de constater
monsieur le ministre que la situation
est différente si le nombre d'enfants en
situation de handicap scolarisés est en
légère augmentation en cette rentrée
2010 9
la situation est très peu satisfaisante
au regard des ambitions que vous
affichiez monsieur le ministre je
n'incrimine pas l'ambition vertueuse que
vous avez souhaité mettre en place mais
elle ne se traduit pas en actes 4500
postes créés dont vous faites état n'en
sont pas puisqu'il participe finalement
à compenser les emplois aidés et le seul
de n'être est loin des 4500 créations
nettes de postes
le comtat le constat que je partage avec
de nombreux collègues avec les parents
avec les personnels éducatifs est le
suivant les moyens humains et les moyens
financiers manquent et beaucoup
d'enfants ne peuvent être scolarisés ou
et l'inclusion que vous prenez
[Musique]